do you remember the first hooper that
you approached with this idea i do she's
sitting right next to me and what
happened so i
i heard her
and i was very humble about this but
she's credited a lot for starting the
hoop dance movement there are lots of
people that do lots of different things
with hooping
anna
took this thing that people were doing a
lot around their waist and with great
pleasure at concerts and turned it a lot
into performance art and so she used her
entire body and made it very very
beautiful and inspired a lot a lot of
people to want to dance
and what's crazy is kind of is a dance
partner you become very self-sufficient
and i think that's very freeing and when
people started seeing what anna was
doing they went off and did their own
thing with it and that's partly what the
movie's story is a girl that takes it to
the inner city and really builds up
self-esteem with kids and makes them
feel singular and special and you know
keeps them off the street it's
inexpensive you can get really good at
kids are really amazing at it yeah
they're in their bodies and so tisha
credits anna because she saw anna
hooping somewhere and they everyone did
their own thing with it there's a woman
from south africa who had lived in the
states for a while
she had been sexually abused and came
here to sort of recover and she's an
actress and she found herself by being
in a troop with anna and she lights them
on fire and really sees it as a healing
tool and has worked with other kids in
south africa it helps you get back in
your body because it's a very safe way
to re-enter it um actually sas has a
really great way of telling that story
of how she started hooping um because we
were at a desert music festival and i
saw her from across the the dance floor
picking up the hoop dropping it picking
it up dropping it but i had seen her
dance earlier and so i knew that she
would connect into it because she was a
great dancer and i literally ran across
the dance floor because she i could see
that she was getting frustrated when she
was about to give up and i was like no
no no like just give it you know i gave
her a couple tips and then you know and
then it was started to spin around her
body and she was in and that's kind of
how she tells the story she says you
know anna thank god that you didn't let
me walk away from that hoop because it
completely
walked into her life and transformed it
in so many beautiful ways like
specifically because it revolves around
this very sensitive part of the body and
if you've had abuse like that you shut
that down you avoid it you go away from
it you know and the hoop kind of makes
it impossible it's touching you you know
you have to have feedback you have to be
in action with it and so it awakens a
lot of healing specifically for that it
attracts a lot of women that need that
kind of healing without even them
thinking about it it's very unconscious
and you just find it kind of just
occurring and you're like whoa this
little toy is all of a sudden healing my
entire being like how did that even
happen
you